es una jornada dramática aquí en la
región de Emilia romaña me encuentro a
unos 50 kilómetros de las costas del mar
adriático los residentes De esta zona
están todavía profundamente sacudidos
muy afectados por lo que han vivido el
miedo La angustia ante la fuerza del
agua que en muchas casas de la zona
arrasó con todo a su paso aquí ha
llovido desde hace unas dos semanas de
manera casi ininterrumpida esta tarde
encontré a una familia de la zona que me
mostró su jardín devastado su casa
completamente llena de barro estas
personas me compartieron sus
sentimientos de impotencia ante este
desastre y también su preocupación
porque según las previsiones mañana se
esperan nuevas lluvias en la región
13.000 personas han sido evacuadas y
unas 50.000 viviendas están sin
electricidad el gobierno italiano ha
prometido apoyo financiero un paquete de
ayudas Debería ser anunciado al concluir
un consejo de ministros el próximo
martes